what are some of your favorite film
characters of all time and what makes
them so cherished do you characters
that's a great question usually it's the
film's you get asked about Randall P
McMurphy Cuckoo's Nest Nic Cage is
character in leaving Las Vegas Bodie and
Point Break this day this is just what's
coming to my mind you know as soon as I
leave I'll think of others those are
some examples I mean I got there's so
many well let's talk about let's talk
about Nicolas Cage's character okay
leaving Las Vegas so why why is he so
special to you I don't know that movie
really touched me man
like yeah I was very moved by it when I
saw it I'd never seen anything like it
I'd never seen him do anything like that
I I understood his sadness I really did
it I understood that alienation I got it
not and not even necessarily relative to
myself just relative to the world and
maybe a little bit myself and I had a
lot of compassion for him that was one
of the first times I remember as a
viewer like really feeling that I didn't
feel but um I just really identified and
felt for that guy and I wanted it to be
okay for him maybe he's like a very
poetic soul you know lost there's so
many of those guys I mean people that
would that was definitely one bori and
Point Break Patrick Swayze's character
is the complete opposite that movie for
me was like like on the road for for you
know generations they really turned on
the lights for me and philosophically
and a lot of us I think I was 17 when I
saw it I was just figuring
and something that he says I think he's
giving a speech to his his surfer bank
robbery crew on the beach and he's
explaining why they do what they do and
it had not been a bastardized it but
it's something to do with you know we're
we're not gonna you know everyday inch
along the freeway in our tin coffins to
a job that destroys our soul and I'm
like yes that's what I've been trying to
say and try to understand like the few
years I've been on this earth them that
exactly nails it so I think when there's
characters that more films or characters
that make you rien things and reexamine
life and and how you think about things
you have a memorable character for sure
that those are some of them but um I
mean there's so many I wouldn't even
know where to stop I think with um
Nicolas Cage's character and leaving Las
Vegas - there were times when he was
super fun he was ki chaotically fun yeah
and and damaged but there was just you
could just I don't know I enjoyed that
movie to read the book it's a really
good book I did not know the author kind
of lived that well this is a fear and
loathing you know that's the contrast I
know this is an author named John
O'Brien and I think he had lived this to
some extent but he said he was a
beautiful writer and the book is
wonderful I know that I doubt you
actually didn't know that it's oh is it
an adaptation it's not it's just lose
grip ease about it it is okay Wow
yeah it's a wonderful book I mean
obviously know right right the outcome
but the prose itself is very beautiful
[Music]
wow did you see bodies rest in motion
because there was a cat the best
questions didn't know I was like there's
a--there's a character very similar to
that in the movie it's Bridget vonda's
boyfriend in the film someone to eat Tim
Roth yeah uh-huh
it looks sort of a similar loosely I
mean I probably saw when it came out in
yeah I think that's when I saw it okay
yeah I think I saw more recently than
that I've watched it again but anyone
stayed with you I mean it yeah well
because he has a very similar
personality to the Nicolas Cage
character mmm like this lovable but out
of control sort of mess yeah and not a
bad person but just overtaken by things
that you know bring chaos into his life
and so I just just has a very similar
feel yeah yeah I had a review that yeah
you know it's good 90s movie night
there's something I know a little man
Tate such a great film
you